This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey, this is season five,
episode 51 of The Chris Abraham
Show.
I think I called the last
episode something like episode
40, but it was actually episode
50, so I'm sticking with it.
Nobody took my hole.
So it's actually going to go to
100 episodes in season five.
We'll see what happens.
Maybe 63 episodes, since that's
my magic number.
Anyway, today's episode, Gonna
be a Rainy day, is about
America's current destruction is
based on the chemotherapy
against American right wing
extremists and extremism rather
than actually from right wing
extremism.
Racism, anti-gay, anti trans,
anti Asian, anti black, anti L
GB, TQIA.
Plus that the moment that Trump
even got close to winning the
election, there was a a, you
know, either a informal or a
formalized by any means
necessary strategy, which.
Was salting the earth and we
have assaulted earth.
I feel like a lot of doctors
these days are saying that that
there are certain cancers that
men have, like prostate cancer,
that generally do not kill the
patient.
They are cancerous, but they
tend not to.
What is the term?
They tend not to mastic, not
masticate.
That means to chew.
They tend not to infect the rest
of the body and kill the
patient.
And there is a belief that maybe
people with prostate cancer do
not get extreme treatments such
as radiation and chemotherapy
and so forth.
And that radiation and
chemotherapy and so forth is
just extraneous and is does more
to destroy the immunosystem than
it does with regard like this is
all changed now that there's
much better and targeted
antiprostates tumor systems that
are based on.
Gene therapy and based on
specific DNA based targeting and
all that other fun stuff.
But let's just I'm going for an
analogy here.
I just don't want you to.
I just want you to know that I
realized that the science moved
on.
But in many cases, how many
people, And I'd love to know the
number, How many people succumb
to chemotherapy rather than
their life if they just suffered
with?
Their cancer in the 1st place.
And what about the quality of
life?
What about the willingness to
live?
What about the pursuit of?
What about the pursuit of
suicide and self?
And you know, wanting to end the
suffering and the suffering
being mostly not from the pain
necessarily of the cancer, but
from the.
Lack of will to live from, the
fatigue and nausea and all the
other secondary effects of the
cancer treatment.
Now that's always the balance in
any in any environment but in a
in a in a Color revolution
world, you do the equivalent of
of fire bombing.
Maui, in order to lower the cost
of living right, you make major
cities completely unbearable and
disgusting and all the rich
people leave and quite possibly
wrench will decrease or people
will just shut shutter their all
their buildings until the prices
become more favorable.
And you know, one might say that
in terms of salting the earth,
it's become kind of a de rigor
strategy in every environment,
right?
You have the salty earth
strategy in Ukraine right now.
Very literally.
The East and the West are
salting the earth when it comes
to the Donbass region.
If you can't.
If we can't have it, nobody can.
And I feel like in many ways
this is what happened with
regards to Trump.
I feel like when you go into
Trump's actual and legitimately
actual plans for his four years
now, they're completely
different.
Now he has a goal of vengeance.
A goal of vengeance, right?
But it's impossible to make this
argument because I think that
the same people who salted the
earth and completely gutted
America, started a identity
politics cold civil war, have
defamed all white Christians as
Christo Bascis have.
Try to retype non binary and L
GB TQIA as being the standard
bearer and men and women as
being some sort of of of como
dia obsolete binary kind of.
White supremacist, patriarchal
definition of othering that one
uses to say there's a man and
there's a woman and never the
twain shall meet.
So I mean I started seeing this
on the way into Trump.
And I mean, it would be really
funny if at some point
someone's.
Whatever someone's messaging or
chat app or whatever were to
come out with this sort of
shadow government day.
When I worked back in the 2000s,
I worked with Arianna
Huffington's group, which was
this whole Shadow Convention.
And with Shadow Convention was
kind of all about like.
Creating a shadow, if you will,
government that was
contradictory and antithetical
to the goals of adventurism and
war mongering and conservative
politique and Western hegemony
and white supremacy as defined
by.
The George W Bush presidency,
right?
Like, I could get behind that.
I was really anti George Bush.
And it was exclusively because
of his his adventurism, you
know, because of Afghanistan,
which I also thought was an
unjust war.
You can't attack a country for
the behavior of separatist
terrorist cells, right?
Like the ISIS and Al Qaeda.
And Daesh were were not national
or countrybased organizations,
right?
Like the people who bombed.
Sorry, the people who allegedly
flew planes into the Pentagon,
into the Twin Towers were, you
know, not Afghanis.
They were not Pakistanis.
They were not Iraqis.
They were not Iranians.
Or, as everybody says, they
were, you know, first of all,
whatever.
Like, what was the real
narrative of that experience?
However, based on the narrative,
these were all Saudi.
These were all Saudi people.
The bin Laden family is a
cosmopolitan jet set, a rich
construction development company
infrastructure.
Just like, you know, like.
Like any mogul like Trump or
whatever, like in many ways,
Trump is not the definition what
Trump does, as we see from
experience what Trump does, the
lifer gubbies, as we used to
call them.
The gubbies would have nothing
to do with it.
People with dot Gov e-mail
addresses would rather.
Would rather Lahaina burn
completely down.
Would rather the world go to
seed than ever let than ever
give agency of the office they
even when they said that they
when all it was like equivalent
to when Muslim terrorists.
Give up all of their moral and
ethical obligations to Islam,
such as they're praying and
they're not drinking and they're
not sexing, and they're being
modest and they're following
their strictures.
When you are amongst the enemy,
you need to be able to act in a
way that would not draw undue
attention to yourself, so.
Even people really close to
Trump, it turns out, who were
simping after him, who were
bending the knee, who were
kissing his hand, who were
saying, you know, the king has
clothes when the king had no
clothes, right?
So, you know, hence everybody,
everybody in the entire.
Universe that could be
attributed to, either one way or
the other, neoliberalism and
neoconservativism.
This concept of of of pro UN,
pro NATO, pro adventurism, pro
colonialism dressed up as an
agency.
Neocolonialism is defined.
In fact there should be a
synonym which is to say
neocolonize equals exportation
of democracy.
Cultural hegemony is defined as
you need to be free and your
freedom needs to be
neoliberalism and
neoconservatism and you, your
democracy, needs to.
Be a culture of of atheism, of
humanism, and of selective
selective equity and selectives.
Egalitarianism.
Which is to say, if you're out
of line if you do not, if you do
not fit in, if you do not.
If you're not willing to comply.
What you're doing is hateful and
dangerous and antidemocratic
because democracy is weak and
democracy has a glass jaw and
democracy is always fragile.
And we will go to any will
preserve democracy at the end
of, at the end of A, at the end
of a gun.
The barrel of a gun.
So if it takes totalitarianism
and autocracy, if it takes
temporary Tierney so as to be
able to like radical, radical,
radical mastectomies of America,
radical mastectomies, anything,
cut off everything.
Cut off the arms, the legs, cut
off the breasts.
Remove the uterus.
Hysterectomy sitting here.
As long as the patient survives
in our image, it is all worth
it.
Quality of life be damned.
Yes.
You don't have any arms or legs.
You don't have the ability to
reproduce.
You don't have.
Any way to suckle child?
The definition of a woman is is
up in the air, so let's say all
sin, and I'll use a lowercase
sin because I'm not talking
religion, but everything awful
that has happened over the last.
1617 eighteen 1920 to 1.223 You
know, seven or eight years.
Like let's just say that all
those things could have been
prevented.
If people would have followed
chain of command, they would
have realized that the President
has certain abilities to do
things, has certain privileges,
has certain.
Controls is the, if you will, is
the you know boss of the
executive branch.
Let's say all those things are
true.
But if you don't, if you're not
willing, if you so, back to by
any means necessary, one of the
biggest arguments.
In The Hague, when the war
crimes tribunal was throwing
people in jail and they were
going pretty far down the chain
of command, the rank and file
were saying I was just following
orders, right?
So the whole concept of
following orders in.
In support of diabolical Nazi
fascism, Second Coming, killing
all brown and black and Semitic
peoples and sending Muslims and
Mexicans and Jews and Hindus and
and and and S Asians and Asians
and.
To a gulag, to to send them
asunder and so forth.
Right?
Like that's a moral thing to do,
right?
A moral thing to do is I refuse
to follow your orders because
your orders are in support of a
Hitler.
So no matter how much damage to
the economy.
To inner cities.
To sexual politics and racial
politics and gender politics and
feminism.
No matter how much, no matter
how much the right has been
actually activated, and no
matter how much the populace
left have been driven into the
arms of the populace right, and
no matter how incidental.
Like, I wouldn't say that seeing
Jimmy Dore and Russell Brand and
Joe Rogan and Tulsi Gabbard and
even Tucker Carlson.
And I mean, he's a right wing
guy.
But like Jimmy Dore is a
populist leftist.
Russell Brand is a populist
leftist.
Honestly, I'll tell you.
Tulsi Gabbard is definitely a
populist leftist.
There are and you know, there's
the horseshoe theory, which is
both extremes have more in
common with each other than they
do with the establishment
center.
So what happens when the
observant Muslims, the observant
Catholics, who in no way like I
just recently spoke to a Muslim
friend?
I just recently spoke to a
Muslim friend and if he said
that his he told me that if his
son is gay or non binary or
trans, he'd kill him.
And that in order to prevent
that like if anything starts
happening to that in a real way
to his little family, he's going
back to Albania.
Like fuck this, right.
So you have you have religious
Ados, American descendants of
slavery blacks.
You have Catholic Central and
South Americans.
You have immigrant Africans who
are either Coptic or Orthodox or
Muslim or or.
And then you have Eastern
European, Eastern Ukraine
Orthodox, Russian Orthodox.
You have Greek Orthodox.
You have, you have certain you
have people from South Asia who
are very traditional in terms of
gender and so forth.
You have, and you have lots of
people who have no concept of
the rule of law, who have like
their first generation right.
They have no concept of the rule
of the law.
They have a concept of might
makes, right?
They have a concept of, you
know, if you take it, you keep
it.
And I'm really afraid of this
activation because even though
according to the media, it seems
like, you know, if you combine
black, brown and Jewish people
and add African American people
and then add L, GB, TQIA, it
feels like it should be 5060 or
70% of the population.
But if you Add all those groups
together, it's still, it's
barely 20%, right?
So there's 80, Let's be
generous, 70%.
People who are traditional, who
believe in God, who might
believe in angels, who believe
in Mohammed, peace be upon him,
who loved Jesus, who loved
Krishna or loved Vishnu, who
believe that a family is a
mother, father, and children who
believe in an extended family
that includes grandparents,
great grandparents, aunties and
uncles.
There are traditional values
moving here.
There are Since there is a great
favoritism for people to keep
their own culture, maintain
their own culture, and support
their own language in their
family, there's very little
incentive for anybody to
assimilate into Western
liberalism, neoliberalism.
There's very little chance that
short of second or third
generation that these children
will become humanists or or or
atheists.
And honestly, the only real
atheists there are are people in
the Academy of Education.
The only real atheists and
humanists are scientists or
people who have a undergrad or
actually a graduate in a postdoc
in a PhD or an MD or even.
There are plenty of Jesus loving
accountants, plenty of Jesus
loving MB A people.
There's plenty of Jesus loving
engineers and there's plenty of
Jesus loving lawyers.
But if you get into the world of
first principles and evidence
and and all that kind of stuff,
the world of mysticism in the
world of magic and the world of
of the paranormal in the world
of the supernatural, in the
world of the of the holy, go
right out the door.
But there's so few people who
have graduate degrees in
America.
I mean compared to the, you
know, 380 or 350 or 340 million
Americans, there are this is
going to be a big it's, it's
sort of like if I want to speak
your language, it's sort of like
carbon, carbon, carbon
sequestration, is that the right
word, sequestering carbon into
the ground, right.
And if you tear up the ground,
then all the carbon gets
released in the air.
Like, that's always the fear,
and probably a little bit to do
with the popularity of the
phrase let sleeping giants lay,
which is to say that they're
they call it the moral majority.
They call it the silent
majority.
These are people who unless you
increase the price of of beer or
challenge the right to guns or
make gas too expensive, they
will not be activated.
And to be honest, all three of
those things are in the in the
air right now, so it'll be
really interesting.
I just know that whenever I
listen to Alex Jones, he's
constantly telling his listeners
I was tricked on January 6th, I
was tricked on January 6th.
It was a complete honey pot bait
and switch.
I was tricked.
So don't all y'all take up arms
against anybody or anything
because that's going to be a
trick too.
Like and all that fun stuff.
So anyway, I'm just rambling
today.
It is episode 51.
Today's my dad's birthday.
I lost him in 1995.
He was 58 years old and had a
massive coronary and we died in
Fajardo, Puerto Rico.
And by saying we died, everybody
in my company fell apart.
So I had to take care of all the
details, but I lost something
that day.
Man, I never got it back.
I you know, it's heartbreaking
to lose a parent.
It's even heartbreaking to have
lost my mom about 11 years ago.
Still heartbroken about that,
even though she wasn't
necessarily my favorite person,
but she was also my favorite
person.
Does that make any sense?
So happy birthday dad.
I love you.
August 10th is his birthday.
Anyway, talk to you soon.
Lots of love.
Bye, bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.